So Shoke, I tend to think of the difference between the incremental concept
learning we've talked about in the past and version spaces in terms of
a bit of a visualization. We can imagine a spectrum that runs from
a very specific model of a concept to a very general model of a concept.
And we can imagine that this circle represents where our model currently is.
If receive a new positive example that's not currently assumed bar concept,
we then generalize it a bit to move it to the right.
If we receive a negative example that is currently included in our concept,
we're going to move it to the left and specialize. As more and
more examples come in, we start to see that our concept keeps moving around.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Notice that they would use it a model to refer to a concept. In fact,
they use in concert with models almost interchangeably. This is actually quite
common for certain kinds of concepts. We have discussed earlier prototypical
concepts when we were discussing classification. But prototypical concepts,
concepts are like models. What is a model, a model is the representation of
the world. Such that there is a one-to-one correspondence what is
being represented to the world and the representation itself. As an example,
in the world of those blocks that made arches, I can actually make an arch in
the world, and then I can build a representation of that particular arch.
That's a model of the world, so the concept of an arch and
the model of an arch in this particular case can be used interchangeably.